some big changes are coming to
valerian's rank system today and they
might just help some of you climb out of
the lower ranks we also have some dope
new skins but there's one thing missing
where are the chamber nerves
before we get into the video i just want
to remind you guys to check out our
twitch channel where liz has been
hosting her navct watch parties on
friday and saturday we'll find out which
two teams will be representing north
america and copenhagen so it's pretty
hype alright so last week we showed you
all the new map pearl and after playing
it all weekend i can honestly say that
it's pretty fun but there's a lot more
to today's update than just a new map i
hope you all managed to achieve your
rank goals last act because there are
some big changes coming this episode
most importantly we have a new rank
ascendant now the ascendant rank sits
between diamond 3 and immortal 1 and it
has this cool new green icon so i'm sure
many of you see this and you say
oh no i'm already low elo and now i have
even more ranks to try and climb but
this might not be as bad as you think
riot says quote we believe our lower
ranks have a few too many of you
especially bronze and silver when we
were looking at rank distribution we
realized that if we were to move some of
you up and out of those lower ranks it
would overpopulate platinum and diamond
so by adding a new rank we can better
distribute you across ranks keep the
prestige of high ranks while helping
better define the skill level of each
rank end quote those of you who felt
like you were stuck in low elo should
have a better time climbing to gold and
even platinum for some of you platt
won't feel quite as special now but
maybe now's your time to squeak into
diamond i think this is a great change
as someone who finished the act and low
diamond but definitely played with and
against a lot of
boosted immortals i'm happy to know that
they're gonna have a much harder time
trying to get back to that rank in fact
this change should benefit just about
everyone except for those who struggled
to hit and maintain a mortal one
with the new rank the highest you can
possibly place is ascendant one instead
of diamond one so high elo players will
likely start their grind there they will
also need to hit higher mmr targets in
order to hit a mortal and eventually
radiant here's what tarik had to say
about the rank changes they're ascending
into radiant yeah i think it's cool i
think it's cool uh
i think it's good i think it's good it's
gonna make it harder to get into
immortal
which means it's gonna be harder to play
with me but the new map and the new rank
aren't the only things coming with this
update we also have something that i
love talking about skins the prelude to
chaos bundle is easily one of the
coolest skin sets we've seen for a while
just look at these things they sound
[ __ ] incredible and the finisher is
badass if you've tried out the blade of
the rune king melee then you'll
recognize the animations because they're
the exact same but the visual effects
are pretty wild yeah
i'm definitely buying that the new
battle pass is also pretty cool for 10
the shimmer spitfire and task force
skins are all solid options and as per
usual i love the new player cards skins
rank changes and new maps are dope but
there's one big omission
for whatever reason they still have a
nerf chamber players have continued to
beg riot to nerf him almost daily but
there's nothing in the patch notes that
says we should expect to see changes
anytime soon now this makes no [ __ ]
sense to me whatsoever and as someone
who abused chamber to rank up last act
even i can admit that the dude is busted
after removing one of his trips he's
basically still a killing machine and
riot isn't doing anything about it even
someone like myself who's mediocre at
the game can just pick chamber whenever
they want to win games i know that riot
probably had a lot on their hands
considering we're getting a new map and
some ranked changes but i would have
loved to see any sort of update on
chamber he's basically ruined the game
since he was released now maybe they
just didn't want to shake up the meadow
with copenhagen right around the corner
but chamber continues to dominate pro
play each and every week too assuming
we're back to the normal patch schedule
then hopefully we see chamber nurse in
two weeks
phoenix rework would be nice too but
don't think i'll get my hopes up on that
one just yet
uh
the amount of immortal ones i got you
just like
like i i can tell you the difference
between an immortal one and a gold one i
had this immortal one yoru go like two
and 15 in one of my games and i'm like
bruh
come on man
dude these immortals suck ass